everything I said today you you have to
take it you have to take it you have to
absorb it and you have to use it but
keep it keep it in your thoughts in your
movement and don't outwardly do these
things but out inwardly use these things
that's that that is that is that correct
that's all right yeah yeah I will leave
right don't don't do the things that
don't do that [ __ ] don't do that [ __ ]
it's the essence of it that yeah but I
do what you do this I do want you to go
home when you go home I do want you to
open the back of your toilet
and look into that tank okay just look
into that [ __ ] for lower okay
and the water's gonna be moving a little
bit then you're gonna see yourself
you're gonna see your reflection in that
[ __ ] water such a stream of [ __ ]
so I'm gonna see my reflection in the
toilet tank [ __ ] yeah you'll see a
reflection in that water it's like all
those movies when you see someone like
they'll be at a lake and they'll just be
looking in the water and then just touch
the water in the water just be a little
bit yeah it's very tranquil yeah but you
look into that [ __ ] or or better
yet this has been better idea you take a
[ __ ] backwards oh for God's sake and
you're on the toilet seat like this
backwards looking into the back of that
tank oh my God
I'm sorry no and then when you feel like
at least all your troubles and flush
that [ __ ] that's this that's the
craziest form of therapy I've ever heard
of in my life
and now you can decide of your glass
or your toilet bowl is half empty
okay you don't have to build water back
up again and you watch that water come
up okay see yeah yeah have you tried
this have you tried uh going to the
bathroom in this manner where you're
you're turned around sort of everything
I I tell you I [ __ ] try do you hear
me yeah
you've you've cowgirl the toilet I want
to put someone put you in danger like
that you buddy hey you
you have to look when you're sitting on
when you reverse cowboy that
[ __ ] toilet seat
and you look into that bowl
you are
look you are emptying all the issues you
have into that toilet but at the same
time you are watching this water flush
that [ __ ] that's flushing away
from the this keeps you from looking at
your own [ __ ] to make sure it went down
you hit that bat you just watch that
clean water go out oh that's you
cleansing yourself that's you cleansing
yourself when you see that water go down
into that little hole that little
stopper comes up a little pulley a
little chain a little floaty on that
[ __ ] how much time have you spent
looking into a toilet in your life JB
how much time have you spent you know
you know a lot you really look man yeah
here's another thing oh there's another
thing I'm not just trying to help you
right there's people out there who need
this [ __ ] too no one needs to hear any
of this there's nobody that's being
helped especially by this last one
there's nobody nobody who's gonna be
helped by this reverse toilet
concept it's just I've given you I have
given you leeway on every idea I think
you've actually hit some good areas I
think this last one no I'm gonna put my
I'm putting my foot down on this last
idea I think with your reverse toilet
tank you've lost me you've completely
lost me you I'm telling you it works you
have to
[Music]
see his you're thinking too much about
the toilet the traditional you're just a
major player no you're thinking too much
thinking about the traditional use of a
toilet that is not a toilet no more that
is a body of water it's a body there's
two bodies of water one
toilet do we have a major bodies of
water here one is eliminating all your
wasting all the [ __ ] you've been
through your whole life and one is going
out there to to make it happen but also
refilling with new Energy new life new
thoughts new people in your life when
that water comes back in that's new
energy coming in your life okay okay
metaphorically speaking yes yes oh yes
don't do any of this stuff right yeah or
did you want or do you want people to do
this I told you earlier you you think
about this you don't physically do it
good you got to be there yo Soul got to
be there though yeah your soul got to be
sitting on that toilet okay and you
gotta see it oh well I'm gonna see
yourself sitting there when you're
sitting still if you're sitting down
right now you should you're sitting down
and sitting down position yeah you can
easily do this right here yeah okay
mind will be on that toilet backwards
yeah yeah yeah okay I'm just trying to
help
I'm just trying to help you